but i do personally think it's the best
thing i've ever done in my whole life
full stop
and i was like look you're clearly
insane like i'm
i've never drank air cold and i'm not
gonna touch an illegal drug
but the biggest interference is death
it's not my
i don't choose the time i don't choose
like and we need to change that
my guest today is a friend but he's also
most definitely the most interesting
human being i have ever encountered in
my life he's an entrepreneur
he's an investor but he's also just a
really
nice guy and he's invested and started
companies in some of the most
fascinating industries from
psychedelics to space tech to artificial
intelligence to cryptocurrencies to
fintech
you name it he's in there in fact he's
the single
biggest investor slash driving force
behind the whole psychedelics industry
which is currently trying to cure mental
health disorders
this is undoubtedly the most interesting
person
i know and i think this is the type of
podcast where you're going to demand a
part two
because we spoke for two hours and even
i was left feeling that i was only
scratching the surface and i wanted to
know more
the man i'm talking about is christian
angemeyer and i genuinely believe he's
going to become
if he isn't already one of europe's most
important investors and entrepreneurs in
the same way that people praise elon
musk for all the work he's done in the
us
i think he's europe's answer to elon
musk without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dharva ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
christian i i know so much about
you and the work you do i i know you're
you know i've observed your behavior in
person over the last you know six
six to twelve months um deeply deeply
fascinating but the part of you that i
know
very very little about is your early
years your upbringing your childhood
cute child really
i've only had slithers of that part of
your life so could you tell me a little
bit more about
uh the childhood that made the man the
main point i'm always making which i'm
really
literally happy about is that i was a
very very happy
child meaning i'm still a very happy
person but i think the reason why i'm
groundedly happy is because i had a
great like
how you say childlike upbringing like i
was growing up in a 90 people village
um so in bavaria i literally knew
everybody
then there were a lot of other children
so i'm an only child but like i had a
lot of children
sort of same age plus minus four years
to to grow up with
um and we were literally like in the tv
series we were out
all day like in summer in winter like it
was very much like you would picture
like what is this american tv series
where they
might they on a farm or whatever like it
was like that like sort of
um idyllic childhood yes really idyllic
like
yeah no crime like no risk like i was
literally my mom
sent me out in the morning uh in summer
winter and i came back in the evening
since i'm like five like i was
because there was no risk for anything
like um
yeah so that was sort of the very very
this was till i'm nine and then we moved
to a
town mini kansas city town with like 2
000 people
so it's me nearby like killer kilometer
apart
so it was all very very rural very
which i liked so i'm actually was
thinking about if i have children
when i have children then how to
recreate that which i think won't work
so but like i think it's
great to have nature which is also by
the way meaning already jumping but like
yeah because you know that that would i
do a lot in in
like in mental health work like and one
thing which is really healthy
very very simple uh for your mental
health is nature
yeah like there is even in japan they
prescribe
like a war walk in the forest as a as a
treatment for depression so anyway so i
grew up in these
super nice childhood like i always was
funnily um
very entrepreneurial yeah and nobody
else
is so not in my family not in this
village like
so that was always literally like with
six
my mom still has the so the first thing
which i did when i learned writing was
writing
invoices like so it was tiny bills like
i said oh give me fives
give me five cents for for
salads so i was actually had a very a
flourishing gardening business
so since i'm four like five yeah how's
it going
i'm sorry wrong english terms not
psychedelics
no i i stopped it later on when i was
12.
like you know what this is how i started
my first business but my mom still
remembers that the first thing i did
with my writing
skills was writing her an invoice for
salad and everything
and then i was literally liking a movie
it's very stereotype but i was selling
um lemonade to neighbors then i was
selling lollipops in school
i was selling literally everything like
i made a business out of everything so
i i remember when i went to the my first
cinema um
ever i think it was like seven
um then i was so fascinated that people
are buying for something which is
apparently also on tv
and they didn't get the difference yeah
so then i started charging my parents at
home
when they wanted to switch on the tv
because i was pretending i was running a
cinema
so uh yeah so every literally everything
i was doing i saw
through the lens of a business and and
when you look at your channel my parents
were deeply worried
in a nice way but they were always tend
to be with with kids that are slightly
different but they
exactly i yeah so i look like them so
the
discussion uh if they maybe not my
parents was early off the table
yeah but like sort of from the way how i
see the world and i'm very different
what were the factors the sort of macro
factors at play that were making you
into this entrepreneur at that age but
also the entrepreneur you came to become
it was always there like sometimes i
think for myself i think because my
parents were never around they created
this big sort of void of freedom
and independence which i thought made
this connection in my mind that if i was
going to get something it came from my
behavior i'm thinking about those
factors
that you know freedom you said you know
i've heard you say that your parents
were
very keen for you just to be happy yeah
exactly like they were always like i can
be whatever i want so but
it was not that i don't i don't know if
that automatically leads to
entrepreneurship it could also have led
to me being an artist or whatever like
i don't think there is a connection
between
freedom it's actually the freedom to be
whatever you want and then i think maybe
you
maybe it's genetic maybe it's like i
don't know like uh i really this is
though the point meaning it was
always there there is not there is not a
moment i can think of
where i sort of changed
but it was literally since i can think
since i'm four five
six like very very early it was always
there to make a business out of
everything
in a nice way hopefully that coupled
with some kind of innate curiosity
which is theo said when he did a quote
about you
in sifted he said that curiosity is one
of your real sort of
yeah benny i don't i just thinking if
that was that early visible i loved
school
which i think it was a very nerdy child
as well so i
yeah i i loved actually i did love
school for
an evening now more talking than later
high school for the one reason
and even if i look back now i really
miss it a bit because it was the only
time in life where you
do something for the pure reason of
learning something with no material
sort of meaning i turned that then also
in a business because i started my
my this was my first real business was
when i started a tutoring business when
i was 14.
um and then i um what's that business
tell me tutoring like like
giving sort of other kids yeah because
it was extremely good in school so it
was always the best one
in my school but it was practically
always the best one in like the
bavaria whatever like top ten yeah and
there was always i like to explain stuff
so
so i think i think that still helps me
now because it's part of fundraising
to explain complex sort of things
to people anyway so i liked i did like
to explain stuff
and i did like to um and i was
good in the matter so so i started
tutoring then there was this tiny thing
i i think a bit that
because the teachers very much liked me
because i was always
like uh the good child like everybody
who came to me
automatically became a little bit better
because teachers were treating these
children
more nicer because they were coming to
me so it became these sort of um
positive virtual circle that more and
more parents were like oh god we have to
send our children to christian because
it really works and i think and what
were you doing for these kids
well tutoring like how are you teaching
them teaching the same thing the same
thing because they were these were the
the ones who didn't perform well how are
you calling english tutoring right yeah
and they were your peers they were the
same age the same age or younger no
or younger like it was mainly like a
little bit younger like one or two years
but not a lot younger
so anyway and then i was like after half
a year i was so like
full like i think i worked like
10 15 hours a week uh practically all
the time like it was tutoring like
and then i was like how do i really
scale it up and it sounds not very um
i don't know very bail yeah but for me
this was like the first time i really
thought about business like in an
entrepreneurial way how do you scale it
up
and practically i realized i have the
brand because parents want to send their
children
to me so i was employing other
other pupils my same age or even a
little bit older
and said you can teach under my brand
and you get half of it and i get half of
it so
50 margin and i started employing and i
continuously till my final grade had
like
10 people like always employed yeah who
what you're doing other children
yeah so it was a very lucrative business
um many for
for a child like but that's crazy it's
absolutely crazy yeah and then so you
get to 16 you get to 18. in that period
of your life
i hear that in bavaria they have this
like public service you've got to do
free yeah
i just was thinking like how compliant
do i have to be because then it's all i
think what is it called when it's out of
time is back like nobody nobody can claw
it back like
because what happened is like i was
always extremely libertarian
and in we had back then it changed in
germany but we had back then like the
israelis have still
you had to go to the military for a year
and i think in generally this is wrong
not because i'm against the military but
i think
you can employ people this is a job like
people should want to be a soldier or
should want to be something else but
like
i think as a government meaning in
general i think
the less government the better so i i
was thinking
hopefully this comes across charming but
because i was thinking all the time how
to avoid it
unfortunately i was not daring enough
back then there were tricks to do it
like
you could have had said you you're sort
of mentally ill or whatever like
i was not brave enough to go on with
that
so i i decided to do
um you can you could also opt to do
civil servant i saw it in the civil
servant like
go to a hospital or whatever so and i
tried to be really nice so i picked a
job
which i knew is it didn't really really
require me it was more like
okay you had to put these children who
didn't want to go to the military you
could say you're pacifist
you had to put them somewhere it was not
that somebody was dependent on me
so i was sitting in that hospital and my
only job was
to bring stuff from a to b like whatever
so
then i made an i remember that i made a
um
how you say a proposal that if we
reorganize everything in the hospital
i could do my job in an hour and then go
home yeah so
this was i was 18 and then they were
like okay this is crazy like it's not
really really popular um
so and then i made a decision that i'm
not really gonna show up anymore
um and the only way to do that was to
um to get always like doctors to give me
like um
a letter and so now comes but the
important point because like
till that time i um i was extremely like
i loved learning so i was
actually thinking i'm gonna if if i
would have gone and i think this is
sometimes how crazy stuff happens and
then it changes sort of the whole
course of your whole life practically so
i think if i would have gone
from high school to university i
i would would have just been in that
sort of mode like of
learning being extremely good so i guess
i would have just
went on with what i was doing like
meaning producing great academic
outcomes so to say
so then came this one year which i was
completely bored
so i i got these doctors
um writing me letters that i didn't need
to show up but in return
i started managing money for them
because i was already speculating on the
stock market since i was like
15 16 and i was not bad in it so i
became friends with all of these doctors
even in the hospital i was working
and they were all like well we help you
if you help us because this was the
early days of the
or you know like it was 1998 1999
like this was the stock market boom
whatever so everybody wanted
to be in it so this was sort of my
trade-off for these letters
um and so and i can't be i'm
easily bored so i always want to do
something so practically because so i
was not
the type of person who was okay i have a
free year now and i'm going
just partying like i was like okay i
have a free year now i'm gonna do more
tutoring
yeah and i'm gonna do managing money for
these doctors yeah
and sort of that completely switched my
i
say course like so i wasn't these i
actually
wrote the book yeah and tried to sell
that this didn't work out
but i did a lot of entrepreneurial stuff
just because i had time
yeah and then when i practically went to
uni then a year later i was
sort of mentally not anymore in that
sort of
learning world i was in the okay i want
to be an entrepreneur world
and then i was in this sort of when i
met re-met
actually two guys who finally were my
tutors in a scholarship
i had had during high school already
like for it sounds awkward but for
highly gifted children
yeah so i was sort of in summer
summer school that was university this
where i knew them from we re-met kind of
and they were telling me about this idea
and it just sounded great
and they were like my tutors in terms of
i was like okay these guys are the
pinnacle of biotech um and then
i was let's do a company together and uh
we did and this worked out really well
and
then i dropped out of uni so they saw it
i think this how was this sort of
i think without these one year in
hospital or sort of
one year in hospital not in hospital
yeah i would have stayed in a completely
different path
i hear you talk a lot about you believe
in like the serendipity
spirituality yeah which almost seems
surprising because you're such a like a
scientific
led person whereas you do you do believe
that things happen at the right totally
totally actually i'm actually very
extreme with that so i
everything which has happening literally
everything
this conversation today well this
conversation happens because we planned
it
yeah but like the fact for example that
we met originally
yeah while our mutual friend whatever so
i'm always everything which is happening
to me
which i didn't actively say hey i need
to have a meeting like which is not in
my usual
rhythm yeah i always think
hey it's happening for a reason and also
it's happening for a good reason
even bad stuff i believe in this power
of positive thinking but
like more like people always then say oh
this means like if you wake up in the
morning you're
if you feel great it's gonna be a great
day i think it's more deeper
i believe in this what there is this
great book law of attraction like
whatever you sort of think and
rather how you think not just the
meaning sort of the essence what you
think not like the
detail partly but more the essence and
if you expect sort of good stuff to
happen
you're sort of attracting that yeah you
think there's a do you think there's a
spiritual force that attracts it
your intention moves you in that
direction so look i'm very pragmatic
meaning i
mean first of all i dare to talk about
this stuff because i'm very
also scientific so i'm like look nobody
will think i'm crazy
yeah uh maybe a bit no no joking like so
but the other thing is like
there are multiple explanations and i
don't really care about the explanation
you can have a
very spiritual explanation yeah it's the
force of the universe
yeah and then you give a very pragmatic
explanation that if you continuously
expect positive stuff
then you look out for that stuff and
then it's more like a
a numbers game or like uh yeah but and i
don't care like it
it works tremendously well for me since
i'm 16
yeah and i had these i had some
very crazy things which go
borderline which you could explain
like sort of with statistics or whatever
yeah
um so maybe too crazy with the chat but
but
but like but there were some there were
some things where i tend
to believe in their spiritual
explanation yeah
because they were yeah i think
harder to explain or you can always
explain them with statistics but i
you know what i mean like but i don't
care like it does work tremendously well
for me
okay so going back to this company you
founded with these two your two sort of
like
universities mentors this company went
on to be really successful i think you
said it's worth probably about 15
billion
at last check market cap today but like
i sold very early but very early i sold
when we went public for a billion so it
was it was actually
fun do you regret selling well there's
there's a short and long answer
no because like the short answer is no
because like a that money was the basis
for the rest
yeah b also people always mix up market
cap and share price
so meaning i sold at the lower share
price that it's today
but the share price is not 15x because
they did capital increases there was
dilutive stuff like
so so anyway long story it was an
amazing start yeah so
um yeah it was actually the quickest
biotech ipo
i think in germany ever uh we ipod three
years three and a half years later after
foundation and for a billion so it was
was everything
um and it was sort of i dropped out of
university before but it like was the
sort of
sort of catalyst i would say yeah so i
don't regret that and uh and since then
sort of i'm investing and being
entrepreneur i'm somewhat in between i
would say
i actually sorry when i'm jumping i had
this one story again by the way which is
completely you can serendipitous
serendipitous and like
even a bit more so i remember it exactly
i was
14 years old and i was with my best
friends back then
in munich which is far away meaning for
me this was like
going going to the big street
and we spent the weekend with family
members i mean i really
remember every single detail of the
weekend like what we did and like
where what and we went to a bookstore
which is
for germans who listen who can do places
back then was
like sort of like i don't know iconic
bookstore 100 years old
in munich i think it's still even there
although books are dying out
um smaller so it's in the prime location
of munich
and so i remember it so i go into that
bookstore
and there was this whole i was a
promotion
wall right yeah with just one book
which uh which which is uh the american
think and grow rich from napoleon hill
and do you know like when in movies like
the 14 year old boy
goes in and then the light is coming
down and then the hallelujah is coming
sort of that meaning there was no music
there was no light i was like
that's it think and grow rich i need to
have that book so i bought the book
and it was practically my first kind of
i mean napoleon hill is not as spiritual
as some others but like that was my
journey
into that world of let's say
spiritual infused success
how do you define spiritual well there
is like napoleon hill is
sort of and i love it by the way because
they're all so old like they're all out
of the 1920s
so they they don't have the zeitgeist
which i think in terms of success is
rather negative like
so it's sort of like raw american
only principles yes exactly like
and napoleon hill has this why was a
great entry into that thing because his
view was
if you read minnie the book starts that
he says he got commissioned by
um andrew carnegie who was the steel
magnet
to find out and do interviews which i
think by the way you are doing in a
certain way
yeah with successful people um
and find out if there are common traits
uh
you say tracy common denominators which
make them successful
and he did that with all the famous
people of his time from andrew carnegie
himself to a lot of other famous
people and then he made that into the
book and he's actually saying that
the question he doesn't answer the
question why these uh
rules so to say work he's more a neutral
observer and then the next one is
actually there's a guy called dr joseph
murphy
who wrote similar books but more like
with the spiritual undertone
why these rules work same rules sort of
more explanation why they work
which went more into the religious world
and then you have all the other book and
law of attraction is nothing else
which is sort of the modern version and
the key which is a sort of a simplified
version
of an anyway simplified version yeah of
this stuff like but it's at the end it's
always the same rules
some we think they're god given some
which say look again this is statistics
whatever
but they do work i deeply believe and
these things do work yeah um which is
like visualization
the the way you think it's visualization
is that
the main thing i think is two things is
visualization so i meditate in the
morning and evening but it's not real
meditation it's more like visualization
so i ex
i always have a plan for the week for
the months for the year for my life
yeah and everything kind of
did come true so far so i'm always
thinking what could i add like a wish
list
yeah and now again you can say if you
add something and then you you focused
on it it might come true because you
focused on it there could be a very
banal explanation that
it's relentless execution and nothing
magic and again i don't care it's like
i'm like
well like yeah it does work so and the
visual
i think it's the two things
visualization and it's also these
that you have for example i'm not it
sounds very crazy but i'm trying to not
have
negative thoughts so and then there is a
number of negative thoughts you're going
to have anyway because
you have to deal with stuff when you run
a business but i for example have never
watched a horror movie since 20 years
at least because it gives me negativity
so i
and i go the extra mile so i told for
example friends
when they are too much complaining
meaning i'm the first one
friends can call for a problem but then
i'm like let's go through the problem
that's the solution that's what you're
gonna do but if they would repeatedly
because some people want to not solve
the problem they want to repeat the
problem then like you can't call me
again on that topic
because no negativity yeah so i really
have a rule
yeah so no negative movies i never watch
a movie with has not a happy ending so i
have
people check or i check yeah before does
it have a happy ending
no bad endings nothing which makes me
sad nothing which makes me negative
because i'm not i'm not allowed in my
own religious philosophy to have
negative thoughts
and feelings feelings are even more
important than thoughts because i think
they are the underlying driver so and it
sounds now maybe
cheesy and simplified but i think if you
this is what i'm doing since i'm 14 and
if you train yourself
not and again you will always have an
sort of amount because sometimes hard
things happen
yeah and i don't want to pretend as if
my life was easy because i did have very
hard times in business
but even in those times i was lying in
my bed literally and was like
okay this is not fun what's happening
right now
but it must happen for a very very
positive reason
because this is how your world works and
finally it always
the worst things in my life turned into
the best ones
yeah so because i again and you can say
now maybe somebody would say well
because he
was persistent and he didn't fall okay
then this is the explanation
maybe there's a deeper one again i don't
care i can always come to like so but i
would tell everybody the two things
emotionally is like don't have negative
thoughts just focus on positive sort of
thoughts visualize these are the key
things
be happy so many things that you know
and dare to be happy because most people
are
again don't allow themselves to be happy
and even think it's a little bit
negative yeah so there's this whole
thing happening on instagram
i want to come back to this point about
this movies and because i think it's
very much linked to your whole thing
about
alcohol and stuff this this happiness
equilibrium you talk about
but just quickly on that point of being
really positive and unapologetically
positive and saying listen don't call me
with the same problem twice don't
interrupt my positivity there's this
whole movement happening on instagram at
the moment
where there's such a thing as being
toxic positive it's called it's
[ __ ] like everybody's like no and
they're like getting on this point like
because that's one thing i think i mean
again
maybe so i have to so maybe i'm sitting
there i'm
already so old that there is another
generation i'm thinking about the other
generation
and because i'm reading a lot like very
old stuff and you find socrates
complaining about the youth so maybe
that's a recurring thing yeah
but i really think part part of the
millennial culture
of this victimization and always like
that
is this is so wrong this is so wrong
yeah so
to pre-take a question because they
normally say well you saying that
because you're rich you're white
yeah so i was like okay this is maybe a
point let's go back because
i didn't talk a lot about it but i'm
happy to already like i grew up in these
90 people village
yeah i'm gay i'm actually happily gay
but i
look mean i know i'm i'm gonna gaze in
some 11-ish roundabout
so and i was looking at sort of that
world i was growing up in and i was like
that's not gonna resonate here yeah so
seriously like
and that's very very uh very uh positive
phrase
yeah so in my school people were saying
let's beat up gay people and i was like
that's not gonna end well
so but i didn't think that this is
anything bad by the way i didn't even
think these people were
sort of wrong obviously they were wrong
but i was like they don't know better
i'm not like ah these are bad people i
was just like
be pragmatic sometimes life is not fair
sometimes life is not nice but
you can decide if you react on it that's
one of the other points i really believe
in
that you have these tiny milliseconds in
life on everything
if somebody is sort of rude to you if
somebody says something very bad
and you can decide if you hurt or not
it's your decision by the way nothing's
going to hurt you if you decide you're
not gonna be hurt
yeah so and i was like they don't know
better and i can't by the way and by the
way gay is not what defines me
so i was like well then i'm i'm not gay
for a while until i'm out of here
yeah i can't have because there are
other things which define me like
friends like you know like you know what
i mean like it's not that i reduced
myself to this one thing
and was like and now i need to shout it
out to the world
and in return would have get beaten up
like i was like just like
just don't do it like but don't blame
the others yeah
and then move away someone also i mean i
mean it's all like
don't try to change everybody else work
on yourself and like
and your environment what you can change
like i could have started like oh my god
my life is miserable
and i'm growing up in this village and
blah blah blah and actually
talking about serendipity i'm i'm
honestly i'm but again i'm trained to
see the positive stuff
because if i look back if i would have
been straight i wouldn't sit here
for a very simple reason because i would
have dated
every single free minute i would have
had like yeah and would have enjoyed
that
yeah so but i couldn't so
so what did i do i was working my ass
off and learning all the time
so and if i hadn't had the grades i had
i would have ended the first money i had
i would have never met these guys with
whom i started the biotech company
yeah nothing would have happened i would
have been an ordinary
straight boy most likely smart yeah
but not uber smart because sometimes
it's smart and hard work to get great
yeah it's not all
false not fun so so so the practically
the
if you say like that you say adversary
or the negative
thing being gay in a very hostile
environment and not talking about it and
focusing on other stuff
completely made my life yeah in a very
positive way i
i wouldn't i mean yeah i i'm so happy
that this was the case
yeah and again and everybody should look
everybody has
um limitations and negative stuff
but you should look at it and say they
are there for a
very positive reason and something
amazing will come out of it
i just need to have this continuous sort
of
expectation and optimism and yeah yeah
and you have a real sense of like
personal responsibility that comes
across like
you'll take responsibility for yourself
and your actions like who else i mean
it's like who else should the government
or you know someone else jesus
we see that with the vaccine give the
government a little bit of
responsibility and it goes totally wrong
you don't want anybody be responsible
for you than yourself
so going to this point about the horror
films which i thought was somewhat
connected to what i've heard about your
rule with alcohol and cigarettes you i
hear you've never drunk before ever
you've never had a drink
exactly so there were two reasons for it
they were connected the one again by the
way
the one reason was because i was
actually thinking like
if i'm gonna be drunk 14 15 i'm gonna
spill out i'm gay
and then it's over yeah so so my social
life of being the darling of the school
day yeah exactly now and i was also like
i was very nerdy
so teachers loved me but i was also how
you say school speaker speaker of the
school whatever
so i was socially had a great life so i
was like no
that's not risk then like no alcohol you
could say the wrong stuff yeah
so there was the one thing and the other
thing was that i always sort of because
you do that as a child but in general
and i think it's a good thing like
if you have one weakness in my case the
weakness for the time was being gay
the others you build on your strengths
which was like okay i think i'm kind of
smart and also like smart in terms of
learning smart
i learned very easy i always had the
best grades yeah
so i was i was sort of focusing on that
so i was also like okay alcohol could
take that away
from me uh because i thought it makes me
dumb which by the way does
yeah in a lot of amounts i still
wouldn't drink
but so these are my childish reasons not
to drink and then
i just decided okay i think i have the
perfect equilibrium
like uh being always happy having very
good grades
everything was perfect so i was like i'm
not gonna touch any drug
ever and you still haven't touched
alcohol cigarettes no so i have not i
haven't drank alcohol i haven't smoked a
cigarette ever i haven't smoked a joint
ever
i've never take cocaine i've not
anything like no comment
i did i did actually drink alcohol the
first time when i was sorry echoes
eclectic
coffee uh the first time when i was 28.
so you're good coffee as well i was even
avoiding coffee and tea yeah because it
was a drug it was
almost like the very religious people so
i would have been a good mormon
um so um but then coffee i started
drinking when i was 28. there's
something crazy here where you think
okay so
the guy that doesn't want to upset his
equilibrium
goes on to be the biggest psychedelics
investor in the world which is i think
that was a very good ground because what
happened is
so i had a discussion or dinner it
wasn't a discussion it was like a dinner
discussion like we were say
somebody set us next to each other uh
with finally the joke and said oh
you the guy was very or is a very famous
um
drug researcher like he's the david nut
of germany like the
a drug uh yeah uh adviser to the
government
that uh yeah a neuroscientist and
somebody said oh you should you should
sit next to each other because
maybe you can loosen christian up a bit
and you could drink a little bit of
alcohol so
so this is how i met rhino his name
deputy again
it's no but like exactly like again by
the way everybody else would have said
i remember that i was like oh my god
that's awesome like and everybody else
would have said well
again in every single thing happening i
see
it's good for me yeah so um so anyway so
we had this discussion
and i mean the short version is he was
like look everything you
think is bad is bad like so don't don't
touch it
exactly he actually showed me these and
uh whoever is watching
and maybe i don't know if you can put it
into the the like this yeah so he's like
this is this very famous but it's so um
to the point i mean
david not in the uk wrote the whole book
about the misperception of drugs
but this one like he had this one chart
which david not
made and reina pulled it uh pulled it
off in the internet
where you can see sort of the harm um of
each drug
yeah so how much harm there was this
harm scale and correctly on number one
is alcohol because
in a in a holistic approach alcohol is
the worst
and then closely followed by heroin
which by the way the media used a little
bit against they would not which was
highly unfair because the headline i
remember i think the sun or whatever was
like
oh guy says heroin is better than
alcohol no the
thing is like they're both very very bad
like but alcohol is as well we have
these
and this is the chart that says the harm
to you and the harm to others both it's
it's
it's one second yeah so yeah a chart
that shows the harm that these different
drugs have on you and others
and alcohol is the worst exactly i was
the worst but closely followed by heroin
yeah
and closely followed by um crystal math
or whatever like
everything is bad and i really like if
there is one positive outcome of people
watching that
don't do it but don't do alcohol don't
do heroin don't do crystal meth don't
nothing no there is no by the way and
i'm the most
again pragmatic person because what i
was talking with him was like
is there any drug there could be a drug
where you say oh
it has a little bit of downside but it
has enormous upside
and then you can think for yourself
again you are responsible i don't think
the government should be responsible
to think for myself is there any
upside of me taking that risk because if
i go in a car i came to you in a car
so i took a risk of dying meaning very
low
but there was a risk but i was it's
worth to sit with stephen
and do their podcast like no but
everything we do in life
by the way people should look at is like
risk return yeah so maybe somebody says
oh if i
smoke a joint once in a while it makes
me so relaxed but you should be aware of
the risks
and i think people aren't especially not
with alcohol yeah and if you then still
decide actively i'm gonna enjoy my glass
of wine and i think it's great but you
should know it
anyway so but at the end of that scale
it said
um probably with at the very end these
mushrooms magic mushrooms
and before their endless second sort of
easiest or second
lowest risk is his lsd practically the
psychedelic group
of uh of drug and he was like christian
like
i can't tell you what my host told me to
tell you that you should try alcohol
don't meaning i can also tell you're not
gonna die but like don't do it
yeah uh but you should do actually magic
mushrooms
and i was like look you're clearly
insane like i'm
i've never drank air cold and i'm not
gonna touch an illegal drug
yeah and he was very very uh
persuasive because he was like look
first of all you do bio attack
you started your career empire tech like
i send you
um i sent you all the research i did or
i do
but also which was very cool hindsight i
didn't even
value it back then he was like i did my
phd
with famous hoffman who invented lsd so
so ryan it was replugged into like the
old guard of psychedelic luminaries
and he was like i sent you all what what
he did like read it because there were
all these studies it's not like a
crazy idea meaning again actually magic
mushrooms or
the ingredients of cybin was used
as an approved medical drug in the 50s
by sandoz actually very
at least in germany famous brand um
for for depression he was like look it
was medical
it has no risk as you can see i tell you
as in the older studies
at least read it and again i'm very
curious i was like well
send me i'm so that was actually again
serendipity and
so and now comes the biggest territory
because like so for one year
i was just like not meaning it's not
that i had it on my mind every day i was
it was there like i read a little bit
here and by the way again
i know there's even a book about that
okay right which says
what some people believe is destiny it's
just like if you aware of a theme
yeah it's a little bit like when i tell
you don't think of the blue elephant or
the white
whatever you think of it like so there
is this one book i can't remember
the name which again would be fine for
me like because again it works
was like if you are aware of a thing of
a theme
then it pops up everywhere you'll see it
yeah so over a year there were not a lot
because it was completely not in the
public domain but like they were once
here and there i was like okay
read something again whatever and then
more or less exactly one year later
i was with my best friends who
actually have a stake in a tie so they
happy with my best friends
in the caribbean uh so disclaimer
it was a place uh where where it's legal
um and they had magic mushrooms and they
had it like
it looked like mushrooms like this was
good because i i'm so hypochondriac and
frightened of everything
so i would never have taken anything
which didn't look like mushrooms
so but these were dried mushrooms like
so i was like from the ground yeah i
was like okay that looks real like and
they were like and i trust them they're
my best friends yeah so big shout out to
landon and julian
yeah so i trust them anyway they were
like we grew it ourselves so like
safe we know what we're doing yeah um
and i was like actually calling rhino
and a guy
in germany yes so i'm not mentioning his
last name because i don't know if he
works still in a very famous job uh he
was actually saying the sentence look
as your doctor friend do it
it's the best place best people you know
it's real
it's a certain setting everything is
perfect do it so
so i took all my courage ahead um i was
really like and it
it sounds now i can't say how nervous i
was in sort of
both anxious and positive like it was
like really not
maybe people say oh he's talking about
benchmarks all the time it must have
been an easy decision it was not
yeah for days and i was like okay let's
do it i still know exactly the point on
the beach
yeah because we're going there every
easter and somewhere i'm going to put a
big magic mushroom statue here
uh i really will i really will i know
the guys who are on the island so i
yeah they already know of it actually
the guy who owns the island is now a
shareholder thai as well so
everybody is literally everybody's like
so um
so i did it and it was the single
most meaningful thing full stop and by
the way it confirmed everything i just
said
so because what a lot of people report
is that um that
you it's a very spiritual experience and
in that case it was not just a spiritual
experience but it really confirmed
a hundred percent my fuel life which is
by the way interesting because if we
look now
at people because a lot of people ask me
especially successful people
they're like oh i've read somebody takes
it and then he's want to be a farmer in
brazil
by the way which was my biggest fear my
biggest fear was like i'm gonna come out
of that
and i'm gonna change my whole life
because i realize
that i don't know i want to do something
else hindsight
i tell everybody that look at me and
look at others we have both
we have people like me who come out are
very
even more happy but it for me it was a
very big
confirmation of what i'm doing yeah um
because um yeah i don't know because
like it was a confirmation like okay you
see the world in the right way
everything what you do how you do
you can work on it so i got a lot of
ideas how to
make it better but like sort of the
message was you're on the right path
so some other people come out and the
message is look you
have to do something completely yes what
is why is it different it's actually the
same what it does
i think one sort of how you say
one description of psychedelics is in
general
they you realize or you
um you recognize yourself and all
your sort of positive and all your
dreams
all your trauma and everybody has a bit
of strong must not be a real
so everything and then and some people
and then i was always
hindsight i can say now i was right like
i or i was right i
i was good in it i was always living a
very honest life to myself
again doesn't mean that i say hey i
decided for example
not to tell anybody i'm gay but that's
not from my point of view this was not a
lie
because it's my decision but it was not
a lie to myself yeah it was an active
decision
to just make your life interesting yeah
it was suppressing it that was just like
pragmatically
yeah by the way it was also very simple
there was also nobody to date i was very
simple like
no exactly risk return there was no
upside
because there was nobody who would have
appreciated that yeah
and if there would have been a hot guy
and i was like he's gay i'm gay it was
like hey
immediately like but there was no upside
but a lot of downside
anyway but what i'm saying is like i
always lived a very honest life
um to myself yeah again this doesn't
mean you have to shout everything out
and this was confirmed so other people
who don't live an honest life to
themselves
and lie to themselves and maybe tell
themselves that they are happy with
xyz they might realize on a magic
mushroom trip that they're not like they
need
and this is the other people who change
yeah but so it's very dependent on
yeah but it was just one aspect of so
many
positive aspects and then sort of i i
immediately after the trip had sort of
the idea
okay this should be actually legal i was
actually
not even the first impetus was not that
i should make a company because i was
very sure people must work on that stuff
because it's so
powerful and when i then found out
actually took me two years
i was looking around like that there was
none
then we did it ourselves just to go back
to that point though you you
categorize that moment your first trip
as the single most meaningful experience
of your life
yep today full stop nothing comes close
and maybe i would add plus the follow-on
trips over the last year so
it's not just this one trip i would say
as well but i would
i would i would summarize my psychedelic
experience
and i still like try to do a trip once
or twice a year in a country where it's
legal
yeah i would summarize as the most
meaningful
sort of holistic experience i've had in
my life false yeah for sure like
you do this trip on the beach with your
friends
you you think to yourself you know this
must be legal fast forward
you get a call from one of your friends
called mike no it's like
it's way crazier it's way crazier again
super serendipity so
fast forward for two years i was very
very carefully
looking around and actually not telling
a lot of people about it which was wrong
and if i would have gone on like that
i wouldn't sit here again meaning at
least not no i would sit here maybe
maybe but like not talking about
mushrooms or
psychedelics so for two years i was kind
of extremely holding back so i told my
closest friends
actually the ones who knew me very well
saw that or positive like my parents
were like hey
you became an even nicer child we have
an amazing relationship but it became
even better
so my mom was very quickly saying
something happened in your holiday yeah
yeah so so uh so the ones who knew me
well but like i didn't shout it out and
i was actually very very
careful and shy because it's like
technically
yeah and back then by the way let's not
forget like we're talking about it also
now so easily because
all the books came out we have the
success like compass is listed like
now is completely different than so
anyway
so for two years i was very like low-key
yeah
and then i had and again this is like
maybe the biggest
financial serendipity uh or is there any
like message of the universe if you want
to see it like that because
for two years i was sort of like just
telling friends
very close friends and then i had uh one
other trip within a holiday trip
the main message on that trip was
christian this makes
you so happy you have to talk to other
people about this don't be shy
just good thing will come up things will
come out if you talk about it
so i had a real mission so i got this
real mission on that trip to
sort of be open about it and then
actually from
that holiday i was flying
literally the week after i met a very
close friend and business partner of
mine mike novogratz
um who's big in finance last
yeah so but he's not what i want to say
he's not the guy who would
talk about mushrooms normally and i
wouldn't have had
but he was my test case because i had
the mission the mission was
don't be afraid talk about management
because it's going to be good for you
and the world so i met mike and he
literally mike he's always like that
what's up because
i think i do cool stuff like from a lot
of stuff so a lot of friends are always
like hey
what's new what's up what are you
investing in i was like mike you won't
believe it i just had
a mushroom trip and this was amazing and
i want to talk
tell you about it and he was like this
whoa mushroom like i remember mike said
the descendants like
he hasn't talked about it hadn't back
then
for like 20 years because especially in
the us a lot of people it's like a
college thing like
party journal yeah uh he was like 20
years never heard about it
again since college so i told him all of
my experience
on that trip um and in general amateur
so and he was like very interested
yeah and so the next day literally the
next day my phone rings
mikey's on and actually he said it yeah
he said look christian this is the
weirdest coincidence so since 20 years
or
i haven't talked about psychedelics for
20 years
yesterday you were in my office talking
about nothing else in psychedelics
and this morning my sister or sister her
sister called him
so my sister called me and she's on bali
with these crazy couples from london who
told her they want to start
a company which is working on bringing
magic mushrooms back in the living room
and they need somebody who's financing
them and nobody wants to touch it
and i was like this is such a
coincidence you're in london
in london like yeah and these are george
and katya the founders of compass
yeah and i was like connect me
immediately and i remember this was
january and then we met when i was back
and they were back from bali
in february um 2017.
yeah and i they tell me if we talk about
like
within the meeting i was like okay we
got we're gonna do that together that's
that's what i've waited for since two
years and again if i hadn't taken the
decision
to openly talk about it um i wouldn't
have told mike i wouldn't have met
george and katya we wouldn't sit here at
least not sit here talking about this
one
and the magic motions were the thing
that told you to talk about it's a trip
and you end up being you know the single
biggest investor in the space
a space which is now really sort of main
becoming more mainstream
at an alarming rate a sort of a category
that's exploded from a financial
perspective
um and you've you've fat co-founded and
invested into
the two biggest sort of companies in
this area atai
and compass pathways exactly so practice
co-founded bowser in compass i was more
the seed investor because
it was georges and katya's idea and i
added actually a very close friend of
mine
lars as the third co-founder and i was
the seed investor but sort of i was
there
even before the company existed we were
sitting in my in my living room and
planning it and then when i realized
how positive or it was actually
easier as the wrong word but it was sort
of i had
i had expected more
hurdles yeah and it's maybe sadly
actually
the time which is helping us because
there are so many people
suffering and it becomes sort of also
financially sometimes life is very
the world functions very pragmatic like
in the
moment something becomes a big crisis
also financially yeah the
yeah good regulations api so anyway
whatever it was it was the right time so
compass quickly actually got
fda um fast track designation which was
a big thing
stuff like that so and then i actually
realized oh there are more psychedelics
out there than meaning everybody's
always almost
using magic mushrooms and psychedelics
as the same but like
we have the headline psychedelics a
group of drugs and
pseudocybin the active ingredient in
magic mushrooms is one of them
so when there are more of them from mdma
to lsd ketamine
ibogaine whatever and and compass wanted
always to focus
on um on pseudocybin
so i was like okay then i'm starting a
tie as sort of a platform where we
actually
bring on more more of these compounds
to explore them for mental health issues
of all the compounds in a tie
and i know there's a lot of them right i
think you've got over 13 compounds
different psychedelic compounds within a
tie
um we've talked a lot about magic
mushrooms and that the active compounded
magic mushrooms for anybody that doesn't
know is psilocybin which is what compass
pathway does
of all the others and i know this is
like i've heard you say before this is
like choosing your favorite child
which ones of the psychedelic compounds
is incredibly compelling to you
and really stands out is being able to
have a really significant impact
that's really hard to say every minute
because like
it really meaning because they all have
all all compounds we work on have a
sort of reason to exist or positive like
have a have a place in treating mental
health issues hopefully tell me about
ibogaine then yeah so
so then now it's what i want is the
question is what is your
what what does somebody sees as the
biggest problems or name me the problem
you think is the worst and then i tell
you
sort of which drug is the best like kind
of so so i think ibogaine is this is
interesting because also
because ibogaine goes against addiction
and
there is actually almost nothing else
which works for addiction so addiction
see we talk about his severe addiction
like especially to opioids and heroin is
sort of
i don't know if you can say it on
english portugal you're really [ __ ] up
like it's like
that's one of the really severe mental
stuff like
where most people have um how you call
it like um
relapse relapses like it and then
it's also one of these sort of things if
you look at
i don't know families and friends where
somebody is addicted sort of it's very
like
it's a cancer in in in the social
environment so it's sort of
it's it's but age but or i would even
say any mental health is like
it's always affecting others as well but
i think addiction sort of stands out in
a certain way
and ibogaine is the only drug we know
which potentially i always have to say
with all these drugs potentially because
we are about to
prove it once and for all with
scientific terms
our scientific framework fda sort of
compliant but ibogaine has the potential
to really cure addiction with one
trip yeah and there will be a massive
game changer for the whole opio crisis
uh but even alcohol addiction like it's
not just opioids like
yeah and yeah you know you're trying to
you're trying to make people's lives
better right you're trying to get them
it almost seems like you know because
you've
you've been gifted enough to be happy
your whole life you you're doing a lot
to make sure other people can be happy
on one end but the other thing that
you're doing which also kind of blew my
mind when i met you
is trying to extend life you know you've
got elon who's like trying to save
life on earth but also take us to a new
one and it seems like you know a pirate
on your investment company
is trying to make the life we live more
joyous and fulfilled but also trying to
extend it
and the work you're doing with life
longevity i actually find
maybe even more
[Music]
bonkers like when i first heard about
psychedelics i was like really
and then i spent six months nine months
learning and i was like oh my god like
i get it but life longevity for me is
like really
we can really we can really extend our
lives and you've got companies which are
working on that challenge
so tell me about life longevity is it
possible
i well okay let's so so
let's phrase it correctly like because
even i if i want to sort of say
something very
um pokey i'm like oh we're gonna live
forever yeah
that's not gonna happen for an excellent
reason
meaning yes you could say maybe we live
forever if we really upload
our brain to our computer but that not
that i think that's completely
impossible but i think
then we're not human anymore that's a
different discussion like
so but i would say as long as we stay
fairly human meaning having a body
having sort of the human set that we
have
yeah there will always be an end let's
start there because
the worst case if you live hundreds of
years you're gonna have an accident
somewhere and
somebody blows you up you have a by the
way it's gone like it's a
as a side note i think it's gonna change
once we get older and older it's gonna
change the way
how we look at risk because i already
start avoiding crazy stuff
because i'm like it's not worth it again
risk return like
i have this one colleague i always try
to convince he's 50 and he drives a
motorbike
and i'm like you shouldn't do it like
the sort of statistic the risk is so big
of driving a motorbike
and his answer is well because he's
still thinking his life expectancy is
70.
he's like well but i'm exchanging 20
years if it happens
against my biggest passion and this is a
trade-off worth it and i was like well
hey it's already stupid but if you if
you it's okay if
this is your opinion 20 years against
the risk of losing it
but i tell you like it's not 20 you
already if you're 50 i'm gonna get you
up or we gonna get you up with longevity
science
to maybe 90 or 100 by the way in a good
way so would you exchange
50. and then suddenly you see okay then
he starts thinking because
so and now thinking a little bit further
like if you say hey
our natural life experience someone will
be 200
maybe we stop doing stuff we're doing
now because
it could sort of yeah so but you know
back to your question like longevity
never means immortality because
again as long as we stay kind of human
because there is an accident risk
by the way i also believe spiritually
again
that we don't want to live forever i
think
part of being human again as long as we
say that and we can talk about that as
well because another thing i'm thinking
a lot
maybe we don't stay human in our current
form but
so i think two part of being human
is having an end because that makes
everything we do
yeah so i just don't want it now like i
would have more of it
but i think the the sort of the lim that
there is a time limit on being human is
actually
which makes us thrive yeah and which
makes us
everything special everything special so
i don't think i want to take that away i
just want to extend
the joy yeah doesn't it just become
relative again then so if you live to
150
but right so so what i really believe
what we get
in the next
maybe like 30 20 to 30 to come it's i
think it's gonna come way
quicker than people think is that we're
gonna get life expectancy
up to to a time or two
to a to a to a size to magnitude where
we want to die
and i think it's even like this will be
a range and some people might already
say
we've had nerd i had it all i had enough
birthdays enough
um christmases i know so some people
want to maybe leave to 300 but i think
we're gonna
give people that optionality sooner than
we think
and then i think dying will be like this
is my vision like it's a celebration
i would someone say look guys i had it
all i love you
love life but i really think i'm ready
for whatever comes maybe comes nothing i
don't know but like i have an
expectation but like
yeah but whatever it is i'm gonna finish
it now throw a big party
say goodbye to everybody and then go out
on my own terms on my own time i think
that's gonna be
sooner than we think you whisped there i
have an expectation
well i think there is another life like
i think it's a continuous uh
cycle but that's not a spiritual
question like but like i i very much
believe we have an eternal soul
yeah i don't even think there is a
number but first of all again i come
back which gives me a lot of thing
i don't believe in the christian thing
that we have anything to prove that's
already starts because it
means you're not worthy and you have to
prove yourself worthy like it's like
you i think everybody should be deeply
happy and do
exactly what he or she feels is the
right thing to do now by the way again
this is i think what people realize
on the on the psychedelics is like they
i always like to say like which is maybe
a good way to describe a psychedelic
trip
like since we're young and again
maybe my parents were like better than
other parents in avoiding that
but since we're a baby people start
telling us
what we should do what we should not do
how we should be
how we should think how we should so and
i always say like there is your
soul somewhere like from what the form
of your soul is like
but there is somewhere the level of you
use and again
the problem is when we have this
discussion and what i want to avoid why
i'm sometimes so blurry is that
if you start using religious terms then
some people might be
set off yeah or pushed away because if i
use the word soul or god then a
christian person might have a different
reaction than a muslim person than a
then a hindu person yeah interestingly
a lot of people who went through
psychedelics have sort of the same
description because so
so anyways it's by trying to use as
neutral words as possible so let's call
it soul or inner you or whatever
and then you have all these sort of
external
sort of garbage almost what other people
put on you yeah and and i think some
people
literally lose sight
what they really are and want so and i
actually was always very good so
what i realized under my trip that sort
of so what happens under a trip
sort of all this garbage is taken away
so you really look at
you but you and you are real
naked sort of form like for me i mean
like
you recognize yourself all your fears
all your
wishes all your whatever yeah and
interestingly it was
for me it was still a great experience
but it was not so different
so which told me okay i did a good job
before psychedelics
to sort of be again true to myself
and i don't believe in what what some
faiths
say that that oh you have to be worthy
because you are worthy yeah
and you are great you just should live
the life as
sort of it is fit for you and again this
is for everybody it's different but you
need to know it yeah
so so but to compare so this is my
belief and then so and be so
so there is no okay i have it's not like
a computer game
where you have to reach a level and do
certain things and then come to the next
one
i just think it's like an endless
positive sort of
cycle of experiences yeah so and i
definitely know that somewhere and i'm
gonna
want to go to to the next level is the
wrong word to the next experience
yeah um but for now i want to actually
extend this one
a lot of people don't get to live and
this is what i was thinking is like
this this idea that people will get to a
point in their life where they say do
you know what i've had enough this has
been great
i j would you do you genuinely believe
you'll get to a point where maybe 150
whatever what do you think
i think someone is going to happen like
i maybe it's very late meaning i hope
but again
i think this is the ultimate meaning i'm
already pissed about the government
interfering in my stuff in any way
but the biggest interference is death
it's not my
i don't choose the time i don't choose
like and we need to change that so
i think the biggest sort of liberty
everybody has
will be choosing his or her own deaths
but you'll always be curious the world
will always be changing
they'll always be go on like a long time
i i i'm trying to understand if i
if i genuinely believe that christian
angermeier will ever get to point where
he's bored because you're such a curious
but it's great if that is the case i
really don't know like meaning
but i'm just saying i believe like again
i think there is a moment everybody will
come to that
maybe it's very very great like i'm
working on it like
and you don't think death is in that is
a especially that age is like a natural
thing i hear you talking about it as a
as a bug
or as a disease or something well that's
i would say
definitely aging is a disease something
is wrong so something
is i know how the 20 year old christian
looked and who was and felt and by the
way my dna
is the same like it was when i was born
like it was when i was 20 like it's now
but
something of the same dna it's like a
little bit we know how the house with
the
construction plan of the house is the
same and
some why the sort of minions who
who translate the construction plan into
the
building yeah change it and not to the
better from age 20 on like
a cray hair whatever like so but we know
still it is there like the original
source of information is there
our dna so we just need to find out
it is super simplified what changes the
translation of our dna
into mistakes and into what we call
aging yeah
that's a very simplified view but it
shows you that it's not so natural
yeah because it's not that your dna is
if if it would be natural maybe your dna
would change you would say we can't
change that
yeah but it's not like your dna is the
same until you die like so we just need
to make
sure that the translation happens like
when you were 20. so by the way i deeply
believe not just that we can slow down
and stop aging we can reverse it
because again i know how stephen and you
are still obviously at your prime
yeah but i know how christian in his
primes
looked like you know what i mean
yeah and we can't bring it back so
sometimes yeah
some animals live for a couple of days
though so i take like i look at take an
evolutionary perspective on this and
think like you know there's some like
flies that live like four days
but it's enough maybe we are there at
the moment to escape the evolutionary
velocity maybe that's the pinnacle
where we sort of start becoming i know
because i don't mean it like in a
plasphemic way i think we're meant to be
like gods in our own way
yeah and we start now to go to the
sort of source and construction of life
ourselves and i think that's an
enormously curious thing and like yeah
maybe that's what we meant to be i'm
rather on the positive side
this is not blessed for me or whatever
but this is like what
god set us up for so to say by the way
every single religion it's very fun
nobody ever i don't think i love
by the way and you know we can't say
today that there is a big thing coming
out
about religion and and science of
religion but i always loved that i'm
always was finally drawn to the mystical
side and the
religious side and aside of what we
discussed on that what i call spiritual
side i was always always very interested
in the history
of religions and interestingly a
one sad actually happy and sad
observation is that
in the very core religions are the same
they all preach the same good stuff
be nice be nice to others and then
once they become an organization the
[ __ ] starts yeah so
and and also one what most religions
have
just going through but yeah literally
most religions have the big ones
is that they at the very beginning say
that we are
a part and a mirror always it's the
english term that we are an image of god
and we don't talk about that because now
everybody's like oh if you
if you want to live forever but a lot of
people
again if you want to defy aging and
there are a lot of people that oh you
want to play god
yeah this is a lot of different there
are bottles and i was like but maybe
that's what we meant to be because if i
go to the bible
it says we are the image of god so maybe
we are
meant to play god because that's what we
are in a philosophical way so i don't
think it's
not ethical at all i think it's the
ultimate actually challenge we have
to solve yeah um the other rebuttal i
would
i thought the first time i had about the
the possibility of extending life was
that you know we'd have a really aging
population where we'd all be so it's
interesting you talk about reversing
aging but we'd all be 170 and slightly
like
you know slow doesn't make any it
doesn't make medically or
a sense we won't be 150 and super old it
doesn't make sense you can't extend
lifespan that much without rejuvenation
it comes at this
thanksgiving nobody wants to be like
because by the way
that's what most people fear though why
they
it's interesting how many people reject
the idea of living
very long it's none of her ever living
very long but the one of the very
banal reasons is that they automatically
think okay if christian would
succeed in making us live 250 they take
okay i know a 90 year old
granny from of mine and she's not in
good shape and now they add another 60
years and
they're like no that's not what i want
but that's exactly but that's not what's
gonna happen in the moment we can push
life expectancy
way further than 90 it
it goes hand in hand with rejuvenation
and then
more people want it and what time frame
do you expect
i think we're gonna see
step really really tangible steps
forward the next 20 years
yeah and then let's say 20 to
40 laters like by the way which is not
that far
yeah and um and also
um the um this is gonna change society
meaning everything
and interestingly every politician i
talk to things like
well that's far away and i was like no
it's not it's not that so far away than
you think and like
it's gonna affect us sooner and we need
to talk about it about
about social systems about anything yeah
uh it's gonna be one of the massive
black but not a negative way by the way
i think it's gonna be good but like i'm
an eternal optimist like um but like you
know
it will be a massive change for the
world
but let me drink this delicious drink
what's it sure
i called it like in a commercial in that
we should like leave the lane it's like
hopefully who will you yeah yeah
human fuel human film okay it's a very
good name
yeah that's right who came up with that
name julian oh yeah
um so switching because in fact the
topic the topics of conversation we've
discussed are super interesting
but personally the things that i find
most fascinating about you
are you're just like ridiculous
ridiculous work ethic and i've talked to
some of your friends i spoke to aaron
i spoke to people around you just to
confirm what i thought
and the intensity and the amount you
work i think is just like staggering i
think i'm really hard working
i've seen you in action around the clock
over the weekend the fact that we're
doing this on a saturday i don't
normally record the podcast well it's a
hobby it's like
it's like having fun it's not like work
but i know it yeah my point is about you
know
in culture people talk about this term
work life balance and i think you've
kind of responded to it there
very easy there shouldn't be a work-life
balance there should just be one
continuous
hobby it's my view on it people should
love what they do
in a way obviously you do different
things and i love more things
so but like i i always said since i'm
16 or actually 14 since i have my
tutoring
if i would call it work-life balance
then i have a shitty life
because it's just work but my work is my
life and i love it and it's integrated
and
most of my friends i work with and like
even like friends who didn't this is how
i came to the movie business because
just like i had friends who were actors
and were in a movie business
and then i was like maybe we should work
together we should find a movie like
it's like
yeah i don't want to see it as a
separation separation
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're going to start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
let's talk about more personal things so
relationships how does someone who works
as hard as you
find any i'm presuming you value what
relationships can
bring you well a complicated topic is
working progress
welcome to the podcast
now it's like no that's work in progress
so that's like because obviously like
i'm so much in love with my work
that um that it's always it's hard i
think for another person
although i think i can try to be very
uplifting because i would try
and say the same what i told you is like
i would tell every
partner like you have to find you can't
expect from me to get give you meaning
you need to give yourself meaning and
then we can be happy together
yeah but this is unfortunately not how a
lot of people work like
so it's very easy that's sort of
i have a quote on instagram my best
performing whatever it says um
if we're dating i want to be your second
priority i want your first priority to
be you your passion is your future
if we're happy alone we'll be happier
together yeah that'd tell us
i'm happy alone by the way yeah i i'm
also like an introvert extrovert so
people think i'm very extrovert
and i can be and they want to be like
can i like to
host parties and dinners and do things
like that but then i want to be alone
actually
a lot so do you value
and tell me the value of a relationship
in your view
of like a really good committed
relationship do you value it
that's a complication right so
um because because if i say no it sounds
brutal no no and i don't mean it like i
i think it's more
the answer is more complicated so
i built myself that i that i'm sort of
very like independently so so i
value relationships a lot
so that's the real answer but i i'm not
in the concept that one should stand out
so i rather have groups so i i believe
that or a belief like i do have like 10
but not one like 10 very very close
friends
who most of them i have since very long
time i actually extremely value
relations
but i'm not saying okay there is this
one relation
in my life which will completely stand
out from the rest which is maybe a
um a complicated thing for racism i do
think though this will change
once you get children yeah so which i
want so
that's sort of the yeah um and by the
way i also do think people change
like and um and i don't think the core
view changes and like the core but like
you can make adjustments so i know for
example that
when i want children or once i have
children
that i have to make adjustments because
i just want children if they have the
same happy childhood that i had so i
want to be either
no dad or a great dad yeah so and then i
know i need to make adjustments so
but then it's worth it and then it's my
active decision to take it
how is it you are the busiest person i
know it's just thinking then i'm
thinking is this the busiest person i
know you probably you're the busiest
person i know
i'd say have you struggled to have
romantic relationships because
of that busyness um like you know like
uh
interrogation occurred what
these are the things no one talks about
right i sit here single struggling
so i'm like i'll ask christian because
he's way busier and i'm struggling so is
there any hope for steve
yeah i'm totally lying
it's funny this feels like a bit more of
an uncomfortable topic for you
for some reason no it's just very
private it's not uncomfortable i will
tell you my
views in private easier because um
100 000 people watching exactly hundred
thousand viewers yeah
now it's getting really like cringy um
no it is definitely a problem full stop
like yeah and you realize that you're
gonna have to adjust if
yeah and then you always say like okay
you do that
the issue is like what i thinking a lot
how do you know when to adjust
like in terms of because you would say
romantically would say you adjust when
the right one comes how do you know that
the right one comes
if you don't have time to figure out to
the right there is this a little bit
and i haven't figured that fully out
you're someone
looking at the past 40 years of your
life that does whatever he wants to do
and isn't actually very good at
adjusting unwillingly
you've never been good in your life
story at doing something unwillingly
exactly you go the way christian wants
to go
and i just i wonder i'm like when will
what will be the catalyst you said kids
may be there but we'll be the catalyst
that makes christian
adjust but maybe it's a romantic thing
you really like love at first sight i
mean again
the good thing is that i i deeply
believe
that makes me very common that coming
back to what we had
this i i deeply believe it's gonna come
at the right time
and i know that i'm sort of enough open
for it because it's the same like with
business ideas or the same with other
stuff in my life
again if you open open heart open mind
you're gonna see it when it comes so
it's not it's a little bit like with
anything else that like
you don't have negative thoughts don't
think oh i need it now like
yeah so it comes when it comes like
because everything in my life came at
the right time
why not this one so i'm very that's how
i see it
well i guess at the macro level by the
way if in the moment things came
i can just say now business stuff but
like i get it business is my
like when psychedelics came and then the
business meaning that's
sort of very a big part of my time
allocation over the last
like four or five years was in the into
the secondary business i made space for
it
and so i'm always like it's not again
when things comes you realize
that you you realize the message and
then you make space for it
but there's a chance you said that you
might be obstructing
it from coming and happening because
you're so preoccupied with no
i'm thinking about that but then my
conclusion is then usually that or is
because again like i'm because romance
is maybe but it's not maybe it's maybe
not like
finding a good company maybe that sounds
no very um
very non-romantic but i don't mean it's
romantic because i also think finding
companies very romantic or very very
uh emotional yeah if i look for example
the psychedelic business i think that
but i do actively again it's not that
i'm ignoring
it's what i said before my my philosophy
of
not having negative thoughts doesn't
mean that you cannot analyze
sort of stuff and sort of look on the
risky side so i do think about it
is my life how i lead it maybe
preventing
to have sort of the one and only
romantic
um experience yeah my conclusion is then
mostly
that i'm like okay no because like it
will come at the right time and then
you're gonna realize it and then you're
gonna make space like you make
like i make space for everything else
it's so funny because because you're
such an eternal optimist
i almost can't get you to but that's how
it works bad things happen to me as well
bad things are there but my mind twists
it around or twists like
this is what i'm really training since
i'm 14 since like what's the book in
music like every so
throw it to me a negative thing and i'm
i'm maybe a little bit puzzled for a
second or for example
even like this is how it works like
things even if things in our portfolio
don't go well i'm like a little bit like
shaking for a moment and i'm like
where's the good thing
and how can i turn that in my mind how
can i see the upside
yeah it's fascinating
because i was yeah i'm trying to get you
to you know the reason why i started
this podcast is because
i sometimes i want to highlight that for
all the great things people see that you
know
people watching you thinking i would
want to have all these companies and
manage
two billion of assets and all these
things but there's always a there's
always
some kind of down not downside but
sacrifice we could say
that's happening and i'm trying to get
out where that sacrifice is
and the problem is you are happy so
and you're pursuing yourself so it's
hard to identify a sacrifice when you're
that opportunity
exactly i know what you mean i just try
also as a message
not to see it like i think people
shouldn't see it because that's the
negative story about success the
negative story of
a success is that people see people
and say oh i want to be like them yeah i
would like to have the wells i would
like to have xyz
then they can't immediately have it
because by the way it's a long process
and you need to work harder but
and then they tell you oh they must have
gone through a lot of sacrifice
yeah and then this is a little bit what
calms them down or
they they have a lot of bad stuff like
coming with it i think that's the wrong
way to look at for both sides like i
think the right way to look at it should
like
do i really want that is this really
what makes me happy
yeah and then it's by the way not that
easy just meaning everybody would say
like oh yeah i think it's like
simplified money makes me happy but then
again do you makes it happy what comes
with it but i don't want to call it a
sacrifice because
i wouldn't do it if i would have to
sacrifice stuff in order to get money
because it's not about money anyway by
the
way
money from a certain moment on is not
really
the driving force there is there is that
there isn't meaning that there is great
research it's not my
it's like that for from practically zero
to x
money gives you happiness because it
makes your life easier
so but then somewhere you're not going
to spend it because then when it becomes
a figure
yeah and then it's about do you love
what you do yeah
so latest then yeah but like so i don't
people should see not this
you can't see i don't know wealth
or anything separated from the
the process of how you got there yeah
and then it's not about saying oh the
process was hard and sacrificed
it's like is the whole process what i
love doing
then you should throw you sort of or is
it something else
what i love and then you should not
though envy other people
because that makes you miserable as well
you should always embrace what
the problem is people often don't know
what they really want
yeah and then again psychedelics give
you like but like in the moment you
embrace what you really want and maybe
like like a housewife maybe really loves
it it's not something where she should
say oh i'm
just a housewife and somebody else is a
big entrepreneur
maybe that's what she really wants in
this life she maybe wants to have
children
take care of them and take care of him
in exactly way but it's about
knowing that actively not letting other
people
put you in that position or let
circumstances put you in that position
but like
actively know yourself is that what
makes you happy yeah i've written about
this at length in the book this idea
that like
um but obviously the huge force in our
lives at the moment which whispers in
our ear that we want to be something
else is like social media and
society to say you've got to be a doctor
your mum might say or instagram will say
you've got to be a
billionaire and really you just want to
be an artist that dances in croatia you
know what i mean exactly
embrace it but again you need to know it
like by the way i think
as much as i love tech that's one of the
other topics which
which really like sort of how you say
keep me aware yeah but
keep me away at night is something in
the world we live in
or actually something in the world we
are building because we we're
reconstructing
the world in any form and people i think
have no
no real glimpse yet how crazy this will
be
yeah we're going now people think we
were in like a 20 year of tech boom
which is true on the one side but if you
really honestly there is this famous
quote which i love to use from peter
thiel
who said we wanted flying cars
and we got 140 characters on twitter
yeah
which says practically if you look at
the last 20 years yes we had a tech boom
but more or less i'm simplifying yeah
what changed is the distribution of
goods amazon
now we're not shopping anymore we're
getting it delivered but it's still the
same goods yeah
and social media changed communication
changed
but we didn't go to the fabric
of society industry and ourselves
so now we're starting going to
reformulate and re-change
the fabric of ourselves longevity we're
going to really make
not just five years ago maybe we would
have hundreds which change everything we
change
and this is all interdependent and in a
moment we changed the fabric of our body
or then we changed the fabric of society
because society is very much
linked to an 80-year life expectancy
yeah flying cars are now really coming
literally we have
fly yeah we have flying cars now so yeah
we're gonna go to mars somewhere and
it's gonna happen
maybe twenty maybe it's gonna happen so
the world is gonna change like we have
never seen it before
so and i love it yeah and you love it
and maybe even the people who watch that
love it because otherwise they maybe
wouldn't watch it
but like the majority of people doesn't
yeah so and i think that's one of the
underlying reasons
which makes the society more and more
depressive
or mental health because like i think
there is this enormous
fear um and people often have like i
think
it's another word for gut feeling like
you have you can't really explain it
what makes you nervous
but it makes you nervous and i think
that's what happening so i think the
sort of the world as a whole except of
some internal optimists and some techies
yeah
are like yeah maybe i like a single
piece i like my iphone i like that
but as an entirety that makes me deeply
uncomfortable the rates have changed
around exactly
yeah so and even if they don't know it
the bus driver
maybe can't fully explain how a
self-driving bus will work
but somewhere he feels that in ten years
it's not gonna be his job anymore yeah
and i think that creates a lot of risk
because the last time that happened
that was when we changed from the
agricultural society
to the um to the industrial society
yeah and you can say now we change from
the industrial society
to let's call it data society
we need a word for it so we're changing
and changing a massive way
so and then so there are a lot of
parallels
of the time between 1875 and 1920
the people were there was this elite
technically who said everything is
possible
you had um it was i think it was in 1870
but i don't know
something when the eiffel tower was
built there was these uh what is it
called world exhibition like
and people were like oh my god i mean
there was jules verne but it was also
around the time
and hopefully i spell him right in
english like he wrote all these books
yeah like the sci-fi books yeah so the
world was already there once
unfortunately we had then two world wars
yeah and you can look at a lot of
reasons why world war one and two happen
and there is a lot of different layers
of
of reasons but i believe that the main
reason is this
sort of disenfranchisement of
the agricultural society who were deeply
panicky like what's happening to the
world because the world the farmer
yeah in the 19th century knew
was disappearing in in front of his eyes
yeah and it's exactly happening the same
again
so could there not be a another reason
linked to that
why people are becoming depressed in the
technological evolution because you know
to start this podcast you said about
the importance of nature and i've read
studies about you know prisoners
who face who face nature versus a brick
wall are 30 percent
less likely to be depressed and the the
sort of
very human prehistoric origin of the
human being is one that's in nature it's
one that's in a tribe
it has meaningful connections and the
technological revolution is really
you know i now live between four white
walls alone in a big grey city
could that also not be part of the
reason why people are we're getting less
human than ever
and in fact what i like about you know
when i read about
some of the social reasons why people
are getting more depressed it's because
we're getting further and further away
from
being human this is maybe a little bit
more philosophical but like
if you look at like the things that help
with mental health some typically it's
it's meaningful connection it's nature
it's good diet
no more junk and these are all things
that humans did ten thousand years ago
it's like
we have to go back to find ourselves
again or we have to find
our human place in a world which is
changing
so yes so i i do i do think a lot how
can we
stay human in a world which is changing
that
crazily as it does which wants robots
it's like this
world now would appreciate if i was a
robot more productive no i i no i think
we can adjust and
by the way and i know what we need it's
like and i'm saying that with
all the disclaimers it's not legal right
now and i'm always coming back to that
but i do think some when psychedelics
will be
will be the medication for that
because it keeps us in a certain way
very human but at the same time
makes us very adaptive in our
environment um so that so
i give you is more or less the same what
you said so how i see what do humans
need to be happy i think it's three
things
it's some form of faith and i explain it
a second so it's faith
it's purpose and it's love it's super
cheesy what i'm saying no but like these
are the three things which i
i think make us as a
as as a the combination of these three
things make
make us happily then i think let's go go
through it the face
means any form of um
higher meaning or the other way around i
think being atheist
or believing ritually in a materialistic
world where
if you die you're dead and then you
rocked yeah makes people very unhappy
this is not a again many i made i think
the case that i believe in
in more but like let's it's not even a
case it's just like saying like
factually
i think people need that we need this
why every
society ever developed the religion like
i think we need it why because we
terrorized of dying we don't admit it
i admit it i don't want to age aging
sucks dying sucks and even worse by the
way
dying of people i love sucks so and we
don't talk about it we completely pushed
it away from us yeah
and i believe religion always gave
people that sort of
calmness or a little bit of a calmness
that
as death is not the end you're going to
see people again people you love
whatever so and i think it's important
because otherwise you have this
permanent terror of
death in your head and you might not
have been it but you have second point
is
purpose what i said with the bus driver
people need a purpose
yeah and they need to know why they wake
up in the morning
and and what they're doing so having
said that
uh in front of our very eyes at the
moment like these these things are
dissolving that the purpose is so we
need to find new ones and the most
important is we need love and in a
cheesy way
must not be a one-on-one relationship
but it could be it could be a one-on-one
relation it could be a family it could
be a close friend
could be a community yeah so love on
various levels so and
actually the bad thing is if you look at
where the world is going at the moment
all these three things are dissolved so
faces on a super decline
yeah then purpose is only decline
because we
changing the world and most people don't
find their purpose immediately there
and then unfortunately also communities
are on decline traditional family
structures
but also communities i mean if i
remember if i grew up i had like
what do you call it in english when you
go to like a theater group and i had 10
groups like it was all like
it was it was the sort of the pinnacle
of community we were so
and it was great yeah and i don't think
if you have that anymore in that way
yeah or at least this sort of vanishing
yeah statistically
accurate there's a study in the us which
says um 15 years ago
people would respond to the question how
many people can you turn to in time of
crisis
the medium answer was three it's now
zero crazy like i had ten when i was
young
and psychedelics are giving you that all
of that they're giving you faith
spirituality they're giving you purpose
because you you
re you realize that the purpose lies
within you and you can reinvent yourself
and they're giving you love because you
realize the value of connections
whatever
i read tons of things and this is a bit
of a sideways but i read it great
oh it's really great like what is great
i love it like
he's talking about the hue or he's
drinking it's good i will send you a big
box of it there's different flavors this
one's
berry so we'll send you this flavor as
well but it's also really good for you
it's the reason i'm in
the best shape of my life i've read
something really interesting which again
goes against a couple of narratives i
would
expect from you you said you have 42
pills a day
round about is someone that doesn't want
to mess with the
their equilibrium it's having 42
different pills
yeah but it's it's not it's okay
no no it's like someone gonna put it
online because so many people ask like
so i um first of all i think everything
we take
we eat is an active decision so i like
so if you remember like before the the
the um
the podcast i was looking at it because
i wanted to know what is in it like and
there is
seems to be a lot of good stuff in it
yeah i think that might be one of the
greatest endorsements ever
the fact that somebody who cares that
much about their health that they won't
touch anything bad
looked at what was inside huel looked at
the the vitamins the
the level of protein the carbs and all
of the amazing things it has in it
someone like christian who is a
billionaire and decided that it was good
enough for him
right um christian is obsessed with his
health and
uh and also i guess the other thing is
he really really enjoyed the flavor as
well
he tried two flavors he tried the new
banana flavor which if you haven't tried
i highly recommend you do but he also
tried the berry flavor which
he actually decided to take with him
which was my old
my old favorite flavor my new favorite
flavor is the ready to drink banana
flavor
but um i believe you know someone like
christian who cares a lot about his
health who cares about convenience
and who cares about consuming things
that taste good i believe christian's
the perfect customer for you
if you are someone that is often skips
meals or doesn't always get
the sort of nutritionally complete diet
that you need to function properly
and to extend the length of your life
and to be healthy in your body and mind
and health is just such a good solution
so so i don't
i'm not in the camp where some people
say oh vitamins or any form of
of added stuff is bad because i'm like
everything i eat
is something external going in my body
yeah so and then
my view on aging at the moment is at the
moment
there is unfortunately we're working on
it hard yeah but there is
nothing which really slows down aging
dramatically
yeah dramatically or and or even
reverses it however
there are things which give you a little
bit of an edge
yeah and the edge is not big yeah but
unfortunately i'm not 20 anymore if i
would be in 20
which uh then i would say hey no then
then that optionality would be super
easy if i would be 20 now and i tell
that my god children i don't believe it
they're 10
i'm like you're gonna live for hundreds
of years yeah
so i'm unfortunately fortunately because
i still have the opportunity
and again my decision was like i wanna
work on it because i think i do it
better than others
yeah and then rather trust myself than
waiting when i was doing it seriously
like we're like
i'm like okay but i'm i'm at the
borderline like because i need to hurry
up so
so even if i do something now at the
moment which gives me
statistically two more years that's two
more years like
yeah in a in a race yeah tell me how
these things are
well i think because i'm 20 so i'd like
to yes
so i think there are some some easy
things to do like
um the uh for example sleep is super
important
yeah then um why why sleep important
i mean we could you should do i told you
that you should do a podcast just about
sleep yeah sleep packs barn
last two weeks ago yeah oh you had so
it's perfect like
there's so many reasons but sleep is one
of the core things
we don't fully understand it yet but
like who has practically if you
mean i don't know the exact number but
read why we sleep from matthew walker
like
i think if you if you sleep two three
hours less than you should
for some days your immune system is
collapsing if your immune system
collapsing that your probability of
cancer goes up and i mean
sleep has so many good sleep is so good
for you and neg
too little sleep has so many negative
consequences that so sleep is super
important so i try
to sleep enough for example i try that's
one of the luxury things
uh which i can do because i work for
myself that i don't have
early morning meetings so and i have
always something to do like emails
whatever
but i try that i can wake up naturally
so i never wake up with an alarm clock
as unless i need to fly or whatever yeah
so
um so that's one thing then obviously no
alcohol alcohol is it
is toxic like full stop cigarettes all
all drugs except of psychedelics are
toxic
yeah so don't do them yeah very bad for
aging yeah you see that by the way when
people like
yeah um i don't wanna
say now that i aged well but like if i
go to a
class reunion or whatever like some
people who drink wearing a lot of
alcohol
and eat [ __ ] yeah they look older like
yeah it's like
so so they say is their food like insect
be healthy don't
carbs like sugar is super bad like i
think so so i don't want to go yes i do
42 pills or whatever it is yeah and
meaning
i mean the list would be long maybe
again maybe i put it somewhere online
but i think
the message is because if people jump
from zero to 42 pills they won't do it
anyway so
whoever listens now i would say if you
do the three four five things which sort
of
it's these 80 20 rules i'm trying to
carve out the last
20 but go for the sort of the easy
hard and easy first sleep healthy food
exercise is super important must not be
super hard exercise but like
every day like 20 30 minutes of mild to
medium exercise
as i said no drugs no alcohol whatever
um these are the main ones you're gonna
be significantly healthier and how do
you talk about intermittent fasting yes
oh sorry intermittent fasting is one yes
so i try not to eat for 16 18 hours a
day every day
and once you start doing it you you sort
of
you why why'd you do that why do you
intermittently fast i've always been
curious about it i've never done it
uh because it's very healthy meaning
there are enough a lot of health
benefits your
your blood sugar levels sort of
normalizes which has then sort of a lot
of um
follow-on effects yeah it's also
you lose weight it's very simple like
yeah um
i am i actually have one other thing
that i wanted to ask you about i mean i
i don't i have a million things but in
the interest of
time it was about bitcoin yep you you've
been a big investor in bitcoin
and the future of bitcoin you're bullish
super polish because what i think is
like
all politicians from left and right from
from any part of the spectrum
and by the way i think about a lot i
think maybe it's not even a stupid
decision what they took but like all
politicians
decided that money printing is the thing
to go
yeah so we're gonna see this massive
devaluation of fiat funny and
never before again i really love history
and normally
this happened to one currency or one
country or whatever
at the moment it happens it's it's
happening to all the major currencies in
the world
euro uh remnant b
like us dollar everything is sort of
devaluated at the same time
so and because everything is relative to
each other obviously by the way it's not
just bitcoin but assets go up this is
why i'm on a 10-year horizon
i'm extremely bullish on in general
quality assets stocks bitcoin
anything which is not cash i think the
most
dangerous asset class for 10 years is
cash
doesn't mean by the way there can't be
stock market crash whatever in between
where you want to have cash
to buy yeah so you should have like how
you say english tactically cash but not
like strategically cash
um so but bitcoin and so and bitcoin is
one of these assets
first and then second the world always
needs
a store of value so for thousands of
years gold
was the store value of choice i mean you
think about it how many currencies
were there and many thousands because by
the way always politicians
mess it up always like politicians can't
be entrusted with currencies
full stop it's always a bad idea yeah
always 100
and so people always had gold yeah so
but gold isn't is
also people that say oh bitcoin has no
value gold has no value you can't eat it
it's actually one of these things like
you can't he did
it's maybe nice to look at but like it's
just a convention it's just an agreement
humanity has
and i would go further it's embedded in
our cultural system
there are so many fairy tales and things
about gold
but if you ask a 10 year old for him
it's bitcoin
bitcoin is his pop culture sort of value
and that's exactly a goal so and i think
that shift has happened or is about to
happen
that bitcoin is at least additionally to
gold and someone will
completely make gold redundant yeah is
the new store of value and it's just
you can argue now what's the value of
bitcoin because it's a it's a convention
it's a deal society made that we accept
that
that's the value yeah there is no
nothing more meaning you can add that
and say oh maybe
bitcoin is disrupting the financial but
it's all secondary the main thing is is
it a sort of value not and for me
it is a store of value yeah that's sort
of the main driver of uh
bitcoin is the new gold that's enough by
the way to make it still
go up dramatically compared to gold
we could talk about this forever but um
my last question
and this is definitely my last question
is as you think forward
you know in your future you set up at
the start of this podcast about
visualizing every morning you visualize
and you think about the things that you
want your future to hold
i know if i said to you like what's the
end there is no end i get that because i
understand you're thinking this is a
continuous
pursuit of your own hobbies and
interests but when you visualize
what you want christian's future to look
like saying
you know a couple of decades from now
what are the like
the principles of that future what are
the characteristics of it still want to
look like today you want to look super
sexy and young yes you want to be 20
years old
we're going to make that yeah we can do
that on photoshop no not on photoshop
we're going to make things
because i value human connection
photoshop doesn't work
because you wanted to be cyborgs anyway
so in virtual world so well i think
we're going to be cyborgs i think we're
going to
that's one of the drivers which i think
is still human we're going to merge with
technology we already are meaning
uh what is it called like what you put
on your heart like a scent or like
whatever
yeah yeah it's already like a cyborg
it's just like very early
exactly it's very so but that's the
whole point i
there is no end game because that would
be
kind of sad it's this what it's the same
like with work-life balance to say
if i would just work because then you're
back at these famous
sort of what was it a novel from whom
was it like that or
this old tale where the fisher is on the
the guys on the beach and meets the guy
who
like the story yeah you know which one i
mean like yeah so
where then he comes out oh he works his
ass off just to lie on the beach and
then the poor guy is saying why you
could lie on the beach now
that's the whole point it's about the
journey it's not about
an end point so i don't have an end
point and i never had i just like
try to keep my again it's all about
keeping my life exciting
because if it wouldn't then i would want
to die so keep my life cool
and this by the way this can change when
maybe in 40 years it's not
i'm not a robot like this is not gonna
i'm not gonna be
i'm maturing like oh maturity like i'm
changing in a positive way like
uh maybe in 40 years i decide
that i don't think so but i don't know
like and it's like the good thing is
that i'm open for
i don't want to be already maybe in four
years i look i had now everything i had
on a
in entrepreneurship maybe i want to you
you feel yourself changing and maturing
yeah but maturing is i wonder you don't
yet changing but in
a good way that again i'm trying to
continuously analyze
what now we're back at the word soul or
whatever you would call it
your inner voice is telling you what is
good for me now and it might be that
this is changing over time
so for example i decided decided the
wrong word like i
feel that it's getting time somewhere
not urgently to getting children like if
you would have asked me 20 years ago i
would have said no i don't want children
like
yeah so but it's like hope being open
for that and maybe
in 40 years i'm just making it up now as
an example
not that i feel like maybe i say look i
want to be a singer now got beware and
the world is like no
no no but like maybe i have some new
ideas
which really like are different what i'm
doing now but like it's important to
stay open for that inner voice
because it might change and just because
again so far continuously i love
doing what i do and exploring that but
like you know what i mean like
i can get you yeah so don't put an end
point there is not this one thing
because that would be sad
like if a most depressive day ever isn't
it exactly like
today you lose all meaning seemingly
yeah
well listen thank you so much for for
agreeing to do this you are honestly the
one of the most fascinating people i
i've i've ever met and i i'm not just
saying i want to win
i'm sure you do no no i want to be doing
something creative
like something artistic artistic yeah so
i've i've gone through the same thing
since leaving social channels like i'm
gonna dj i'm
i've done a big uh by the way i thought
it was very cool when you told me that
i was like that's a cool thing i've got
i've directed a theatrical show with the
associate director of hamilton it's it's
theater
it's called the dire overseer live it's
the theatrical version of my life
there's a 50-person choir
sold out already and i said to myself
that i didn't want to
be a label so i don't want to be a
social media ceo i'm a guy that has a
bunch of
perspective and that perspective can be
applied to art my book
which i wrote myself the show creating
music i've got
my first dj performance at festival this
year and i just thought
what if you detached yourself from your
labels what kind of person would you
become
you'd become artistic you'd become
health-centric you'd start businesses
you know
for example i always think i should
write the script because i can't act
when i could like when i'm not good at
it like also you should be always
self-aware
it's not worth pursuing but like i
always tell you maybe you should write a
script i was like because i love movies
i produce movies so
so i so i was like maybe i should and
but again it's always listening to
yourself
what your soul inner voice however
you're going to call it not society
exactly and not outside world is telling
you
you are the probably the most
interesting person i know
in in a really compelling way sometimes
i know people and they're like
successful and i think oh god i hate to
be that person
but you are in like a really compelling
unique way because of your work you do
but because of your philosophy for life
because of this sort of
this i guess like almost i don't know
how they refer to it but this like
how your how your scientific view can
can merge with a spiritual one and a
religious one
i find super fascinating and i think
it's those sort of intersections that
create really interesting ideas
um you're also the most hard-working
person i know um
but you're also a really nice guy oh
thank you really like nice guy
behind the scenes as well and so thank
you for coming on the podcast i think
you know i think your future is going to
be
staggering i talk about you all the time
to my team all the time i'm like you
know because you are very very
compelling in a number of really
positive ways
i think i think the work you're doing
with a thai campus and all of your other
companies are staggering and i think
you're
actually going to be one of the most
important entrepreneurs
creators of our time i think the world
is like
no no i don't really
i genuinely was like i know christian
coming to my podcast now i know in 10
years time
this is probably gonna be one of my most
few podcasts ever because of the
trajectory you're on
and the way you think it's my my
prediction i'm very rarely wrong
and it's been a privilege to work with
you over the last couple of months and
understand that because it's been
inspiring for me
um thank you for doing this today i hope
you've enjoyed it yeah i did i did very
much amazing thank you thank you
thank you people ask me for book
recommendations all the time
and i finally got one for you it's a
book called happy
sexy millionaire which is authored by me
i spent the last almost two years
in jungles around the world in costa
rica and indonesia in solitude
writing this book it's the there's this
crazy thing when you write a book
because
you spend so much time pouring your
heart and soul into it and everything
you know and all of the revelations
you've had in your life
and then there's this barrier which is
that people have to buy the thing
in order for them to get that thing that
means so much to you i wish that wasn't
the case
it's just the way the industry is and in
order to get that distribution and to
get it on shelves you need a publisher
so
please please please if you can if
you've ever liked anything i've
ever produced this podcast my instagrams
anything i've ever said
read this book there was no ghost writer
i wrote every single word myself there's
some real surprises in there it's an
honest sometimes hilarious incredibly
vulnerable
hopefully valuable recount of my life my
journey
everything i've learned across across
the way and really the answer to being
fulfilled to being happy and to
achieving success
it is the most important important thing
i've ever created so i implore you to go
to amazon now or wherever you get your
books
and get that pre-order if you get that
pre-order i'm gonna put you into a group
with everybody that's pre-ordered it
and i'm gonna send you some exclusive
stuff so the first things i'm gonna do
is a series of voice notes which i think
are
um are going to be pretty powerful i'm
going to give you access to some tickets
which nobody else will have
and i'm going to do everything i can to
thank you for for giving me that sort of
nine quid of your money
whatever it is happy sexy millionaire
you can pre-order it everywhere now
and if you do get that pre-order please
do dm me because i'd love to thank you
myself